il est 20 heures samedi soir quand
l'employé de cette station service de
ville d'auch mais victime de ce qui
s'apparente à un braquage un homme
encagoulé le menace d'une arme de poing
en fait un pistolet à billes à travers
la vitre de la boutique
l'employé s'enfuit par la réserve relève
la plaque d'immatriculation de la
voiture des malfrats qui est garé dans
un chemin attenant à la station service
deux heures plus tard quatre hommes sont
interpellés ils ont entre 19 et 20 ans
mon client bêtement il a suivi il a il a
accepté d'exécuter
il a
on lui offre acheter une arme il s'en
est servi on lui acheter une cagoule il
a porté tout ceci sans réfléchir sans se
rendre compte des conséquences de son
acte iv nigauds qui font une affaire
stupide de mais malheureusement
je crois qu'ils sont encore restés dans
dans le jeu virtuel dans les jeux vidéo
ont fait des attaques en gros le butin
est maigre 138 euros en espèces quelques
cartouches de cigarettes et quelques
jetons de lavage la voiture est emprunté
à la mère d'un des jeunes hommes les
cagoules le pistolet à billes ont été
achetées dans l'après-midi en carte
bancaire presque une aubaine pour la
défense de prouver l'amateurisme des
prévenus ce sont des jeunes qui n'ont
pas connu la délinquance qui sont primo
délinquants qui n'ont pas connu la
justice qui sortent n'ont pas forcément
de milieux aisés mais des milieux
éducatifs sérieux avec une stabilité et
rien n'explique en l'état ce dérapage
d'un soir où comme je disais
précédemment il semble s'être laissée
guider bien plus par l'association par
l'appât du gain 30 mois dont 18 avec
sursis 20 mois dont 11 avec sursis voilà
le verdict pour les deux principaux
commanditaires